ist doch ohne aluminiumsalze ihr habt
ihr sicher schon mitbekommen in theorie
gibt es immer öfter zu lesen ohne
aluminiumsalze günther brauer hat uns in
den kommentaren gefragt was es
eigentlich so schädlich an diesen
aluminiumsalzen indio aluminiumsalze wie
zum beispiel aluminiumchlorid oder
aluminium mit roxy chlorid während in
antitranspirantien eingesetzt um das
schlitzen zu verhindern
und es funktioniert so in unseren
achselhöhlen fällen diese aluminiumsalze
proteine aus das bedeutet sie bilden
wenn man so wie kleine stoppen
damit der schweiß nicht nur durch die
poren kommt das hört sich sehr effektiv
an aber irgendwie auch ziemlich eklig
oder wie seht ihr das zurück zum thema
aluminium in größeren mengen ist
gesundheitsschädlich so viel steht fest
das metall ist neuro toxisch das heißt
es beschädigt nervenzellen
wissenschaftler entdecken außerdem
erhöhte aluminium konzentration im
gehirn von alzheimer-patienten die frage
ist nur hat das aluminium die krankheit
verursacht oder hat sich das metall erst
wegen der krankheit dort angesammelt und
das weiß man eben nicht was man aber
weiß ist das aluminium ein sogenanntes
metall östrogen es das bedeutet es
greift in biologische mechanismen ein
die sich um das weibliche
geschlechtshormon östrogen drehen und da
brustkrebs die häufigste erkrankung
unter frauen zumindest in der westlichen
welt ist und zunehmend häufig am äußeren
teil der brust das heißt in der nähe der
achselhöhle auftritt wird ein
zusammenhang mit der verwendung vermutet
wurde aber bisher wissenschaftlich noch
nicht direkt nachgewiesen
die sache ist man kann die aufnahme von
aluminium nicht völlig vermeiden
wir nehmen jeden tag ungefähr 30 bis 50
milligramm aluminium zu uns vor allem
durch unser essen und selbst
der luft die wir atmen befindet sich
dieses sehr weit verbreitete element und
in solchen kleinen konzentration ist es
auch gesundheitlich unbedenklich das
problem ist dass die wissenschaftler
derzeit nicht genau sagen können wie
viel aluminium tatsächlich durch ein deo
über unsere haut in unseren körper
gelangt und vor allem durch kleine
hautverletzungen wie du es basieren
unter den achseln könnte diese aufnahme
deutlich erleichtert werden fragt sich
nur in welchen ausmaß ich würde sagen
obwohl die forschung zum thema aluminium
deos und gesundheit noch nicht
abgeschlossen ist kann man ja einfach
auf nummer sicher gehen und ein
aluminium freies deo benutzen da ist ja
inzwischen die auswahl zum glück groß
genug
schön also meine persönliche meinung ist
dass wir schweißflecken gesellschaftlich
akzeptieren wir komplett auf
antitranspirantien verzichten den
schweiß schön raus lassen und nur dafür
sorgen dass der schweiß angenehm riecht
mal ganz ehrlich ist es wirklich
irgendwie eklig mit diesem stopfen
jedenfalls vielen dank für deine frage
wenn ihr fragen habt schreibt sie in die
kommentare an lassen gibt es hier oder
hier gekommen nicht ganz klar diese neue
nennt card weitere videos außerdem gibt
es noch irgendwo dieses icon beschlossen
da könnt ihr mich auch noch abonnieren